they are chilling details of what
happened in those critical moments at
the bonanza creek ranch when a hollywood
shootout turned into a deadly real-life
tragedy
dressed in full costume as in this
picture he posted before the incident
court documents have revealed alec
baldwin was handed a loaded weapon by a
crew member
cold gun they'd called indicating they
were unaware it contained live rounds
a single shot to the chest killed
cinematographer helena hutchins and
wounded director joel
the investigation into that shooting
continues baldwin photographed looking
distraught shortly after the incident
says he's heartbroken
in a statement the actor said there are
no words to convey my shock and sadness
regarding the tragic accident that took
the life of helena hutchins a wife
mother and deeply admired colleague of
ours i'm fully cooperating with the
police investigation to address how this
tragedy occurred
and i'm in touch with her husband
offering my support to him and his
family my heart is broken for her
husband their son and all who knew and
loved helena
two days ago she posted this video the
perks of filming a western she'd said
riding on your days off born in ukraine
and raised on a soviet base in the
arctic she was named a rising star of
the movie business her loss is
devastating to friends
she has this
i mean tremendous talent is given but
her human connection was incredible and
i think in the film industry which is
extremely competitive this is where it's
really important to have this human
connection it's been reported that
before the incident several crew members
had walked off the set over safety
concerns including misfires of a prop
gun the movie's producers say they
weren't made aware of any official
complaints concerning weapon or prop
safety but would review procedures
safety they said was their top priority
alec baldwin was a co-producer of the
film as well as its star
i can't even imagine what alec baldwin
is going to you go to work
you're an actor you're pretending to
play someone who fires a gun
and then all of a sudden real life kicks
in and you have fired a gun that has
fatally injured your cinematographer and
injured your director
last week a picture of the cast
receiving a safety briefing was posted
this incident is raising serious
questions in an industry that says
safety around firearms on set is number
one on its list of priorities if that's
the case how could something like this
happen
that is the focus for investigators too
for many though it is the loss of a
woman described as always smiling always
hopeful a ray of light
greg milam sky news los angeles